i've learned many things about tailoring
over the years i mean growing up in
costume houses i've picked up a lot and
i want to share my knowledge on how to
create the best fit for your body in a
segment called tinker taylor shoulder
pad
okay one way to make over our existing
wardrobe is tailoring it to fit you just
right and one of our viewers megan wrote
in and she sent us this picture and she
said i've recently lost weight since the
pandemic good for you most people went
the opposite way and i started a new job
and i don't want to spend a lot of money
to buy new clothes help well guess what
megan we're here come on out
[Applause]
i love it
it doesn't look like a sack anymore
i love it so much when i look back at
these pictures
it really did look like a sack and i
feel like most of my clothing used to
hide behind
i was about one week away of donating
this dress
all right step forward a little bit i
want to get you in the best lighting
possible and maybe we'll both take a
spin
all right now we have some life-size
printouts of you because i want to
take you through what we did here
now we gave you
a little
ruching
elastic here and the reason the elastic
is great because it expands to fit over
your head and then once you've got it on
the body it re-cinches but cinching it
in here is also still kind of going to
leave some bagginess in the front so
what we did here
was we grabbed
an
inch on the double now what the double
means is here lift your arm this is the
double
that's why they call it that because
you're actually grabbing two sides of
fabric so you're not taking it out of
one side
you're grabbing it and you're getting
both sides that's on the double so we
just took it out an inch on the double
which really means
exactly two inches we also took it up a
tiny bit in the knee to give you a
little more long leg and again like i
said in the beginning of the show
this i'm never going to be able to get
up in these boots
tinker tailor shoulder nightmare
this area of the foot
is length on your leg oh god it's not
it's not me it's the pants
okay
so
i mean literally i have like six inches
of leg that isn't leg at all it's my
foot
so this silhouette is really elongating
and because we brought it up on the knee
look at the difference in your leg
between that and that
your leg looks twice as long
and who doesn't want a leg twice as long
absolutely
and if you do i don't understand you
all right another thing that i wanted to
do which is just a fun detail is create
a band color rather than a traditional
shirt collar so
we just lobbed it right off and this way
you can still have the decolletage area
which to me is as valuable as this foot
area it just gives a little more skin
it's not too much but it can just make
you
a little sexier let's face it yep
so i love that you're showing this but
to me a shirt collar everything about it
says daytime cash um we also raised the
sleeves up a little bit to again
elongate the arm the longer a sleeve is
going to look the shorter your arm is
going to look i love it
i
love the way you look come stand in your
back
[Applause]
i love it all right as i've asked
everybody here today
how do you feel i feel so good this is
the best i've felt in a really long time
and it's just really fun and today's
been amazing so thank you
[Applause]
so happy amazing well you probably have
a few other items so we're just gonna
throw in two thousand dollars to make
sure you can attack anything else in
your closet
and
remember these tips and tricks i will um
and if you have any problems text us
because i could talk tailoring all day
long i love it thank you so much makes
all the difference you're living proof
of that
all right
[Music]